well China is clearly a threat to our
economy if nothing else and becoming
more threatening what can our congress
do about it Senator Marco Rubio is a
Republican representing the state of
Florida he joins us tonight senator
thanks a lot for coming on you you just
wrote what I thought was a really
interesting a hotbed about China and you
have this line in here which I think all
of our viewers should be familiar with
and I'm quoting you
Chinese theft of American enal
intellectual property alone cost the
u.s. nearly 600 billion dollars annually
eclipsing that combined profits of the
top 50 companies in last year's fortune
500 list that's a remarkable number why
is no one doing anything about that you
know for the same reason that this is an
issue that surprised me you know for
years I kind of been a traditionalist on
it all thinking it did like most people
did that eventually would all work out
they'd become more democratic and then I
started getting involved in the human
rights issues in China and that led me
to kind of understand the broader plan
they have in place and this is not an
economic plan on their part or a
development plan this is a plan to
undermine not just our competitiveness
but the competitive every country in the
world and become the dominant nation the
dominate economic industrial and
technological power and they're using
multiple tools including intellectual
property theft to do that so not only
are they undermining our industrial base
they are also undermining our
technological base through something
called China 20 made in China 2025 where
they intend not just to supply in
America but all countries on earth and
the West in automobiles and passenger
aircraft in in quantum computing and
artificial intelligence they've laid out
the entire industries and they're slowly
but surely carrying out this plan so
this is a threat obviously not simply to
our economy but to our predominance
around the world to our power and to our
values why are American industries not
saying more about this some of them are
starting to some of them are making some
money over there and you know when CEOs
many of these multinational corporations
they consider themselves to be citizens
of the world these CEOs are going to be
gone in eight years they don't feel that
many of them don't feel any special
obligation to the United States they
feel an obligation to maximize return
for shareholders and as
result if they've got a good thing going
over there making money who cares if
they're stealing technology and in ten
years the company won't even be able to
compete with them it's working out in
the short-term and that makes them look
good so that's a part of it others are
beginning to complain but they're afraid
to say so because they don't want to get
kicked out just the other day we heard
to Airlines United and American are
being told that unless they stop
defining Taiwan as a country they no
longer will be able to fly there I mean
they're threatening them with hundreds
of flights and billions of dollars in
revenue
Marriott fired an American worker about
six months ago because the worker put up
a tweet or like they tweet about Tibet
and they fired an American over a tweet
that the guy put up by mistake so that's
what's happening and so we've got a bill
that addresses it and if I could briefly
walk through the five points on it
because they're important number one
please do hibbett the transfer yeah we
would prohibit the transfer of any and
all technologies that are sensitive
things like quantum computing and
Biosciences and and artificial
intelligence and the like the second
thing we would do is we would place a
tax basically on excess Chinese
investment the United States how that
works basically they come let's say they
buy ten billion dollars of fortune 500
stocks that will raise the price of the
stock that will issue debt revenues
dividends they then take that dividend
money and they use it to buy US
Treasuries which increases the price of
the dollar of the value of the dollar
thereby making American exports more
expensive than a Chinese export thereby
destroying our capacity and so this is
not economic development on their part
this is a strategic use of investment as
a weapon to undermine our production
capacity we would also put attacks on
American companies entering joint
ventures with Chinese companies because
what they do is they make you partner
with them and then they steal your
technology your intellectual property
and all of a sudden they become your
global competitor they kick you out and
they put our companies out of business
and these are the kinds of things that
we're going to be looking at and in this
bill to put in place even the playing
field let me just say this this is not
an economic issue this is not a trade
issue this is not a tariff issue this is
the single most important geopolitical
issue of the last hundred years
we'll define what the 21st century turns
out to be I I couldn't agree with you
more and I'm grateful you're saying this
I'm a little baffled why more people
aren't saying it but I hope they will
after hearing you say it so thank you
senator good to see it